recevons le docteur manuel etienne
directeur du centre de démoustication et
de recherche en promo logique bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être là est ce qu à
cette heure on peut parler du nombre de
cas exact décès en martinique alors
normalement il y as en termes de
communication sur les chiffres une sorte
de règle qui impose que ce soit les
niveaux de la cia ya vraiment des
épidémiologistes qui sont des
spécialistes de ça donc le nombre de cas
je le connais mais je leur laisse la
primeur énormément les chiffres sortent
le jeudi donc demain vous aurez vraiment
qu il ya plusieurs cas détectés ça on le
sait elle s'est avérée où se trouvent
les foyers là encore le côté c'est sûr
que stigmatiser les communes on va dire
qu'il ya une commune du sud est et une
commune du centre
voilà une aide en compte tenu justement
du contexte c'est vraiment toutes les
communes fin tous les martiniquais de
quel que soit l'endroit de la prévention
est de mise
est-ce que vous avez déjà détruit les
foyers alors détruire les foyers c'est
difficile à faire parce que c'est donc
une maladie qui est transmise
exclusivement par la piqûre de moustique
autant pour le zii cas il peut y avoir
une transmission sexuelle mais pour la
dengue c'est vraiment de là il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait le moustique donc
contaminés qui piquent et du coup on a
un gros travail que l'on fait donc au
niveau des foyers identifiés pour
détruire ces gîtes à moustiques et puis
détruit aussi les moustiques adultes au
volant mais il faut savoir également
qu'à côté de cela les personnes qui sont
actuellement en train de développer les
symptômes de la maladie peuvent pas
avoir été piquées autour de chez elle
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
mais elles peuvent avoir été piquée en
un lieu de villégiature moment où ils
sont allés au restaurant sur une plage
aussi on va d'ailleurs revoir un petit
peu le moustique peut-être est-ce qu'on
peut le voir le moustique tigre qui est
un moustique des urnes c'est ça alors le
moustique tigre c'est un terme qui
normalement est dévolue à aider
albopictus qui est celui que l'on
retrouve dans le sud de la france
le nôtre c'est aedes egypti c'est un
moustique qui est tigré mais c'est pas à
proprement parler le moustique tigre le
moustique tigre il est vraiment
originaire d'asie c'est un moustique qui
est dans certains pays de la caraïbe
mais pas encore en martinique
donc on est un moustique tigre est de le
reconnaître oui voilà avec justement
cette alternance des cannes noires et
blanches
la très caractéristique c'est un
moustique qui est alors l'activité
essentiellement du jeudi vraiment
essentiellement parce qu'il faut pas du
coup qu'on fonde essentiellement est
exclusivement il est capable de piquer à
2 heures du matin si vous rentrez que
vous et avec justement votre chaleur
votre co2 etc
vous pouvez vous faire piquer à 2 heures
du matin pareil des cj petit il est il
est actif plutôt le jour mais il peut
l'être la nuit le dernier épisode
épidémiologique c'était en 2013 2014
avec trente neuf mille cas comment vous
expliquer ce retour justement de
d'épidémie aujourd'hui alors qu'en 2015
et 2016 2017 non plus je crois nous
n'avons pas parler d'épidémie alors pas
l'épidémie de dengue
parce que l'ajustement il était resté un
petit peu en sommeil les épidémies de
dengue généralement en essayant de
périodicité de 2 à 5 ans voilà donc
c'était 95-97 2001 2007 2010 2013
et puis maintenant à priori peut-être
2019 en espérant que ce sera pas le cas
mais entre temps il y avait quand même
deux heures beau vivre ce qui est pris
le relais puisqu'on a eu le chikungunya
d'abord puis losique a donc à aider ces
jeunes qui s'est occupé de malades
autrement que par la dengue
la dengue le problème avec cette maladie
s'était elle est présente sous plusieurs
sérotypes c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un
seul virus y en a quatre en fait qui
prouve qu'ils provoquent la même maladie
mais en fait ils sont suffisamment
différent pour que ya comme ça des
retours assez fréquent il est très peu
probable qu'on ait de nouvelles
épidémies dans les prochains jours
l'année de chikungunya et de zik à parce
que les souches sont très proches par
contre pour la dengue
il ya suffisamment de bach ayant pour
que on se retrouve avec des récurrences
mais les symptômes qui peuvent inquiéter
alors les symptômes sont assez
classiques
et puis assez dit on d'une commun à
beaucoup d'autres maladies virales donc
on est sûr de la fièvre des courbatures
des douleurs musculaires douleurs
articulaires des choses qui sont assez
communes d'ailleurs à dan chikungunya
zika et plein d'autres maladies par
contre ceux qui se disent intéressés un
quart dingue c'est que je détecte
vraiment très bien il ya toute une
batterie de tests dès qu'on a des
symptômes on a des suspicions il faut
aller et symptômes de grippe
une dernière question sur la prévention
qu'est ce qu'on fait nous rackettent les
raquettes électrique et tout ce qui est
elles sont de sortie et sont sortis les
raquettes électrique les répulsifs les
moustiquaires parce que là il ya à la
fois de la protection à faire pour les
gens qui n'ont pas encore eu la maladie
mais également pour ceux qui sont
malades actuellement il est crucial que
les moustiques ne viennent pas récupéré
le truc sur le virus sur eux et puis
autrement la surveillance des gîtes
larvaires face qui a été dit dans le
reportage qui était très bien la
suppression gouttière il ya des années
on disait aussi que les moustiques avait
développé des choses pour justement
qu'on d'existence bien sûr après les
résistances sont pour les produits
insecticides mais une raquette
électrique là le 2 mai matin le
moustique qui existe à un coût de julie
est pas encore là donc on a encore de la
marge
ok merci merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions merci on reviendra évidemment
sur sur les cas de dengue donc puisqu'il
y en a plusieurs qui qui sont avérés
mais on n'a pas le nombre exact encore à
cette heure merci beaucoup